[Music]
christine is with us christine's in st
louis hi christine how are you
i am very thankful to be talking with
both of you today thank you for taking
my call certainly how can we help
well i'm living a country song so i'm
hoping you might be able to give me some
ethics advice
um
i was a travel nurse until i had a
stroke last year and it knocked me flat
thank you i am at this point i'm
physically able to work um a half day
about two or three days a week so praise
god and healing but that's all the ways
to go
um
while i was travel nursing i held my
tithe aside in a separate account
because i didn't have a home church
and
in the last
number of months i've just had
back-to-back-to-back-to-back-to-back
emergencies so i've used up my
six month emergency fund and i've used
up my emergency fund's emergency fund
and
now i have property taxes and a 640
prescription due next month and i'm
wondering about the ethics of
dipping into that
tithe account as a second emergency fund
in this situation
okay
all right you have children
i do not i am single unmarried okay cool
all right do you have a good
relationship with your dad
uh yes
they have already helped um
i wasn't asking i wasn't asking for that
reason i was asking for another reason
so okay okay here's the thing
god is our heavenly father
scripture is very clear on this
he's absolutely crazy about you
just like your dad is
he thinks you're amazing
and he says to you my daughter
the best way to live your life
is to be generous
generous people prosper generous people
have better lives than selfish people
a baseline for the generosity is a tenth
of your income going into your local
church
now let's get this straight
god
owns the cattle on a thousand hills
he owns the hills
he does not need your money
and if his bride the church needs your
money
then they are confused
because their source is not you their
source is god
so um the bait the tithe is to get you
into a rhythm of giving because giving
is good for you
it's not an ethics
or a moral question
that makes you bad
it's like god says if you eat doughnuts
by the by the box you will get fat my
daughter
don't eat them that's what he said to me
by the way dave don't eat donuts you
will get fat because when i can eat
every donut in a 50-mile radius but is
god mad at me if i eat a donut no he
just said your best life is if you're
generous
and eat healthy and exercise every day
that's your best life i know that
and
my my dad in heaven that loves me
says that and he loves you and he's not
worried about the tithe
so if you need to use this money to eat
you're going to be just fine
don't ever give
out of a sense of duty
or out of a sense of legalism or rules
give because it's the best way to live
your life
right now the best way to live your life
is pay your prescription bills to live
and to live your life and you'll get
back to giving soon enough
okay so lots of grace
on the tithe i'm a tither i believe in
tithing
i come from a trade i got i got saved i
met god in a tradition that teaches
tithing i i teach it i do believe it but
with absolutely zero legalism lots and
lots of grace on it
okay that gives me a lot of a lot more
comfort what would your dad say if he
gave you a hundred thousand dollars and
he said oh you need to give ten thousand
dollars of this to the church and then
you got your back up against the wall
like you do right now would your dad be
mad at you if you use that ten thousand
dollars your dad loves you he would not
be mad at you
thank you that's why i appreciate you
walking me through that that's why i
asked you about your dad's relationship
right there
because this is your heavenly father
it's the same thing
and if i can see a healthy heaven
earthly father smiling how much more so
our father in heaven
amen
you're going to be okay i'm sorry you've
been through this
well god's carried me this far and
now i understand the grace a little
better that'll carry me through the next
step yeah and you you'll get back to
giving you're going to end up giving a
whole lot more than this amount of money
through the course of your life above
the tithe
you'll make up the ground just because
of who you are aren't you
thank you you're a nurse
we love you darling thank you for
calling sorry you have this year it's
tough
amazing